[Music]
good morning today is monday i'm at
nikki's house still if you guys watched
the previous vlog where we were filming
big mood this whole weekend i slept over
two nights in a row casey left yesterday
after we finished filming but the reason
why i slept over though one more day is
because jess nicki and i are gonna be
going to malibu we we booked this resort
that nicki's been obsessed with for so
long and she's like i've been dying to
go here and we finally booked it for
this week we're gonna go relax after
a long shoot weekend we're just really
bummed because gina's not gonna be able
to make it with us she has a nine to
five now and today is monday so
kind of bummed out about that but at
least we get to bond with the three of
us i did wake up with two pimples though
so i have a pimple patch here and a
pimple patch here because last night i
fell asleep and i didn't take off my
makeup and my skin woke up really mad at
me so luckily jess had some patches that
she let me borrow but i got my bathing
suit on baby's doing good yeah cause the
plan is as soon as we get there we get
to hit the beach or the pool or both and
just relax yeah for breakfast i ate some
mexican food some chilaquiles it was
delicious at this restaurant behind the
restaurant there's like a tiny little
carneseria which is like a mexican store
like a meat shop i bought some mexican
snacks for the road for the trip or
whatever just to have with me and i want
to show you guys
so i bought
gancitos
if you're mexican or even if you're not
if you grew up near mexicans you have
most definitely tried this and you most
definitely love it because this snack is
amazing it's like a little cake in there
with like some strawberry filling
surrounded with chocolate and like this
marshmallow stuff it's really good
usually i like eating these frozen and
they're bomb so i put it in the fridge
right now so they're kind of cold
and then i got arroz con leche so some
rice pudding i've been craving this i'm
like oh man i missed this
and then i got some flan
delicious
and then i got barritas
which are pineapple-filled cookies so
the center here it's all filled with
pineapple it's like shortbread kind of
cookie and
the mini mantecadas so these are tiny
little muffins with pecan pieces on top
they're all beam built stuff i love it
and then i got this tamarind candy so
you just like squeeze it out and you eat
it but there's like the seeds and shells
in here so you kind of spit those out
but it's delicious
and then more tamarind candy which is
my mouth is getting watery just talking
about this this is so delicious i got
two of these
but i have a third one in my purse that
i've been saving so baby's gonna be
snacking
really well i actually have to try to
eat this plant and arroz con leche
now because they have to be refrigerated
and i don't think they're gonna make it
by the time we get over there and like
check into our room and like i don't
even know if we have a fridge we
probably do but still i just want to eat
them now just to make sure like okay
cool
they won't go bad because this has dairy
in it so i don't want it to get to room
temperature it'll be gross
kill amigos
we got a bungalow you guys
are you ready to relax yeah yeah
yeah ready to eat actually we're already
requesting i know it was complimentary
champagne
so awesome
cheers oh yeah they have agua frisco too
delicious
uh we're about to go to a room
check that out we got a bungalow that's
pretty cool we're gonna head over now
and then we are gonna we're gonna enjoy
the place relax it kind of sucks because
it's like overcast we don't have any sun
for our first day but hopefully tomorrow
will be better
[Music]
oh
pregnant lady needs help
i know there's stairs where i'm like
yeah we have the pregnant lady behind me
thank you oh let me get my bag at least
thank you thank you from this one i know
there's so many stairs but look we got
our bungalow oh
this is so cute he said that everything
is complimentary in here so like
damn it why can't i drink we got some
water balls whatever's in the bathroom
oh nice i put my bags down in this room
but they both are the same
it's just yeah
who gets the solo bed well you should
you're pregnant i know that's why i'm
like like can i pull the card
would you like can i pull the pregnancy
card yeah i'll take this one forever
yeah y'all all got your boyfriend cards
your pregnancy cards at some point i'm
getting the hair yes
you had a month off last month because
you had a cpa card yeah you did have a
cpa card there's an outdoor shower
so people could see us naked
no
only birds
and me yeah
let me see
the bathroom
oh cute i like all the the more what is
this quartz and then a toilet room
oh a nice robe
oh we have drinks we have refreshments
everything is complimentary too so
there's moscow some soft drinks oh cool
let's grab something beer we got a
fireplace what is that some red bulls
diet coke what is this coconut water oh
yeah coconut is that guava little
coffees
oh there's a fridge so i could have
brought my rice pudding in my flesh yeah
if you made us like hurry up and eat it
before we go it's like hurry i don't
want some good waste what the heck is
this it's complimentary
we even have the expensive water too
look at that this was ten dollars per
bottle at a restaurant we went to a long
time ago oh this is a nicer bathroom
there's like so much more brightness
they already made your choice so oh damn
there was a tub yeah you messed up girl
you picked the wrong room i did it's
totally good i want to soak with my
pregnant self oh cute
can i get to can the baby have this
guess what look at all this body scrub
that's nice you guys can have this
bathroom but i'm gonna use that tub no
yep i'm using it i'm gonna pee in it
first the baby's getting this is the
name
[Applause]
i don't care i'll rinse it
like the baby's a guest too so this
could be for the baby oh cute
little ducky yeah you should take that
oh there's another one
so you can always remember yeah
here you came through who was in there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we finally made it out to
the pool and that is when the sky
decided to get
wet there is no more sun
you hear the thunder
there's thunder now yeah we're probably
not gonna be enjoying any pool really
today is another beautiful day it's
actually really sunny because yesterday
it was raining like at the afternoon
night time it was raining and now it's
like a beautiful day so we're hoping
that it stays like this for the rest of
the day
so then we can enjoy the beach and i
also made my own pregnancy pillow
because i didn't bring my my actual
pregnancy pillow but i made it with the
pillows that the hotel has to look i
have like my head pillow but then these
pillows are so thin i needed to use the
one that i brought to
to like make it thicker and then here's
one for like each side and then this one
goes between my legs but like i said the
pillows are like so thin that my knees
were practically touching each other so
it wasn't some crazy support but i made
it work i got my pregnancy pillow thing
going on here's a little baby
little bump
[Music]
i'm over here like
[Music]
we're on an old lady vacation right now
we're definitely in our 30s
vacationing here it's so pretty it's
nice to sit and listen to the water yeah
that's so tranquil look at all this
nature 25 year old me let's go to get
drinks yeah exactly 35 year old me oh
water it sounds nice i'm gonna nap
glass of wine just take a nap
there's cows here i mean it is called
calamito's ranch there must have been
some animals somewhere because you could
definitely smell like livestock but i
thought there were horses apparently
they're cows they're right there
[Music]
this is the last
oh these are paper straws
oh you were attacking it yeah i'm like
why is it bending so much
i finally made it to the beach it was
like a 11 12 minute drive from the
actual resort but they have this like
cute tiny little exclusively for hotel
guests beach spot right on the water
and i have a menus we're gonna have
lunch here and just relaxing
got some fish
tacos delicioso
look at that look at that view get to
enjoy lunch with that view what'd you
get jess um well i got it for everyone
it's like a bruschetta
appetizer nikki's still way over there
exploring oh she's coming back i know
but i want her to like pretend she's
going to come back and then go do
something else i want to like come back
get your butt over here nicole starting
to chase the bird she's such a dork
yeah this whole time she's just been
exploring the rocks and coming
oh my god
hey big dorks
okay so i found oh
by the way this type of water with all
the rocks is like the best place to go
sea glass hunting oh
so we got clear
oh some amber this one's like a more
reddish one that one's better that's
pretty i like that that that one right
there oh this one oh yeah this different
kind of shell
it's pretty perfect condition except for
that
right yeah she got some fries whatever
just look at this big-ass order oh my
god
okay yeah
thank you all right we're going back to
the resort now we didn't get in the
water it was way way way too cold and
the rocks were insane but we did enjoy
this nice little tranquil getaway bye
thank you i just took a shower and i
took a shower outside
out there it was a little bit cold but
i'm like i can't leave here without
using that outdoor shower so i used it
satisfied i just took like a quick body
rinse i didn't um wash my hair i already
did that last night we don't wash our
hair every day but so now we're about to
go have dinner and spend our last night
here
so
baby's doing good see look i always look
bigger at nighttime for some reason i
don't know maybe it's just me i get to
enjoy that bed all by myself for one
last night and then i finally get to go
home to the hubby and to my isaac
[Music]
what's happening jess i keep getting
attacked
that cow was the bee's friend yeah
there's a yellow jacket there's two me
alone oh no flying around it
there's two there
they want jess's
food drugs
they're meat eaters now
oh wait oh there's three of them now
why do they like your food
um probably the the steak they like
steak
[Music]
try something i have some some essential
oil that's peppermint that might work oh
dang you really attracted them all
your steak brings all the beef to the
table there's a swarm
you look so funny you look like you look
like a dude from mean girls she doesn't
even go here give him the sacrifice
thanks thank you
oh my god
[Laughter]
yeah this morning has been very eventful
as you can see see this is a lesson
don't eat meat okay
they're not bothering me okay
let's see the
cows the funniest way to have your food
ruined i know that's true that attacked
my walls i know i didn't know they were
freaking carnivores at all yeah
you know because we have oh no
no no no it's starting on my plate now
too okay listen we're gonna wait
commercial before we're gonna we're
gonna do this until they come with that
i'm gonna put the plate over your food
okay
i'll do what i did go away go away go
away go away go away oh they're gonna
attack you don't do that
don't do that
sing your baby
they're gonna stick my baby
and to add to this chaotic morning i
just stained my brand new maternity
shirt that i purchased here cholula hang
it just still won't sit down they took
the food away but you have to be able to
run fast
they're still they're still around all
right by the end of it i was getting
attacked so i had to bring the rest of
my sandwich to the room while we're
packing up we're gonna check out pretty
soon i had a great time you guys did you
have a good time yes
yes you're focused yes but you know
what's funny my camera won't focus on
you
cause i'm too hot
too beautiful
it's time to go home and see casey and
isaac now and my kitties
[Music]
you